desde los cuatro puntos cardinales de la
capital española han confluido decenas
de miles de personas en la céntrica
plaza de Cibeles en defensa de la
sanidad pública y para mostrar el
rechazo a la gestión que está haciendo
de la sanidad La presidenta de la
comunidad de Madrid Isabel Díaz Ayuso
Pues el mayor problema es que no la
quieren financiar ni contratar personal
con lo cual la están dejando hundir lo
que no puede ser es que esté privatizada
el dinero público se vaya a la privada y
las vistas esperas sean interminables el
médico de familia me la pide en
septiembre del 2022 y se me da la cita
para junio del 2024 prácticamente dos
años para hacer una ecografía de un
aneurisma que es algo que si se te rompe
no llegas al ascensor entre los miles
que marchas están también los médicos de
atención primaria y los pediatras que
llevan más de dos meses en huelga y casi
un mes de encierro pidiendo mejores
condiciones para poder tratar a sus
pacientes que las consultas sean
limitadas precisamente para eso para
poder dar calidad y Bueno pues lo que
Decimos lo más importante que se
contraten más profesionales que se
cubran las vacantes que no haya
madrileños sin médico ni sin pediatra
inversión inversión
seguimos intentando negociar
administración pero de momento
ellos no están queriendo negociar en
condiciones y viendo el apoyo popular
que estamos teniendo hoy todavía más
motivados y con ganas de llevar esto
hasta el final el próximo 28 de mayo hay
elecciones regionales en España algo que
ha utilizado la presidenta de Madrid
como excusa diciendo que esta
manifestación tiene fines electorales
algo que niegan rotundamente los
organizadores que son las propias
asociaciones de vecinos de Madrid que
dicen que esta situación ha estado
empeorando desde hace más de dos décadas